we have time for one more quick call I'm
gonna go to the nine one six area code
caller from 906 who's this where you
calling from hi my name is Del Mar from
Sacramento all right go ahead Del Mar
all right so my question is about the
James the Moore memo I know you did an
interview with him yeah yeah so my
question is basically what did you think
about the contents of the memo
he had a thesis about you know average
personality differences between men and
women and this may be affecting their
their numerical representation in the
technology sector right so I was
wondering if you thought this was a sort
of a plausible hypothesis for why women
are underrepresented in in the tech
sector I'm open to exploring that I
think it's perfectly fine to explore
when it was Larry Summers who said hey
you know it's possible that there's
fewer women in math because there's some
kind of brain predisposition towards
math for men and away from math for
women like I'm open to that I don't
think it's inherently problematic to ask
that James d'amours memo in particular
was extraordinarily poorly sited like I
think you would you would admit Delmar
that he wasn't claiming to have done any
of the underlying research for the
claims himself right he was citing
research that others had done would you
grant me that yeah I would grant that oh
okay he wasn't doing the research and so
she sure so and if you grant that then
would you grant that it's really
important to check the citations and the
research that he is pointing to would
you would you grant me that yeah
absolutely okay so if you found that a
bunch of his citations went to pages
that didn't exist on the Internet
would that make you question the
conclusions that he comes to yeah that
would definitely make me question his
conclusions it would and if you clicked
on some of the citations and some of
them went to papers but you weren't
finding in the papers where the research
justified his conclusion would that make
you question his conclusions sorry I
didn't catch that could you repeat that
one if you went and read some of the
citations some of the works that that he
cited and
it didn't seem as though the conclusions
he reached actually were supported by
the by the cited work would that be a
cause of concern for you yeah definitely
that wouldn't make me question his his
his rigor and his reasoning there you go
so my problem with James d'amour was
that when you actually look at the cited
work and how he came to his conclusions
it was very poor you had a combination
of citing works that didn't actually
support his conclusions and straight up
links that that didn't go anywhere so am
i open to the argument that he was
making absolutely do I think that he's
the guy to be writing the memo probably
not okay so uh in that case my my sort
of follow-up question would be um what
so if you think that his his his memo
was basically poorly argued even though
even though the the the argument is not
necessarily inherently offensive
basically is is is poorly arguing for a
plausible a plausible idea is that
grounds for four being being terminated
I had a company like Google should that
be grounds for being terminated I have
no idea that's Google's decision to make
but I think you're making one mistake
which is I said that I don't think
there's anything inherently wrong or
offensive with exploring the question
that James d'amour was asking you said
it's a plausible argument and that those
are sort of two different things is it
is it not is it offensive to explore a
proposition versus is it plausible
likely or certain I think those are two
different things but you know what let
me ask you one other thing are you still
really like is the James d'amour memo
still a big thing for you at this point
like is that something you're focused on
significantly no not really I just
thought it was just an interesting
episode and it sort of revealed a lot it
sort of led into and related to a lot of
questions about you know political
correctness and and what do we consider
offensive and you know there's the
thesis that keep you know people on the
right tend to say that political
correctness
what's wrong with it is that it stops us
from being from being able to have
open inquiry and you know people on the
on the Left tend to say that you know
political correctness is just about
being inclusive and it's totally benign
yeah so I was wondering if this if the
verdict on this question would allow us
to you to make a judgement about you
know whether the the right wing story
about political correctness or the left
wing story about political correctness
is is more correct no I don't think
James de maras memo would adjudicate
political correctness big picture Delmar
I got to go appreciate the call very
much sorry to everybody that I didn't
get to we will take calls again next
week